foreign
I've got a new rule for you guys give it
to me I call it the hate that thing rule
I know since my wife recently she was in
our closet you know we share a little
closet together and she tried on this
sweater and she's like I don't really
like that what do you think about it I
don't know like it doesn't matter what I
think right now I can tell by your body
language by your features in this moment
and I think this rule applies well
beyond clothes but I think it especially
applies to clothes we buy something as
an aspirational purchase you see that
shirt it looked great on the mannequin
with the paisleys and oh it went well
with those leather pants that were on
the mannequin and like oh yeah I will be
as sexy as that mannequin if I just buy
that if I put down my credit card and I
take that home and then what happens you
try it on you're like ah doesn't really
fit me well my love handles are showing
I got a little muffin top in this what
am I doing with this and then it just
sits in the back of the closet because
it looked really good in the store under
those lights but when you have it at
home and you're like oh you know what
I don't really like it I don't really
enjoy it it doesn't feel like me I I'm
being honest I kind of hate that thing
and that's where the hate that thing
rule comes into play if you try on a
shirt or you try on a kitchen utensil
Ryan puts his toaster on his head
sometimes
it's not on Tick Tock
if you try on something from your closet
or from anywhere else in your house and
you're not absolutely like yes hell yeah
this is one of my favorite pieces of
clothes or worse if you're like oh I
just don't really like it
then get rid of it if you hate that
thing the next time you try it on
you can give yourself permission to let
go because you're not going to magically
start liking the thing that you hate
right now isn't it funny though because
what if every time you're like do you
guys like this shirt do you guys like
this movie do you like this drink and
everyone's like yeah it's amazing what
does that mean well we go oh okay maybe
something's wrong with me yes maybe I
should just buy it you know maybe I
should eat it anyway and by the way if I
really dislike the shirt that I'm
wearing I feel uncomfortable it feels
unnatural and I come in here and even if
TK and Ryan are both like genuinely oh I
really like that shirt on you it's still
not for me it's for them but I don't
wear my clothes in order to impress
someone else that's actually really
uncool right yeah to always try to
impress other people the most impressive
people I teach this in my how to bet how
to write better writing class the most
impressive writers are the ones who
don't try to look impressive and the
most impressive fashionable people are
the ones who aren't trying to impress
you with their wardrobe they simply look
confident and secure and grounded in
whatever the they're wearing yeah no
just to be clear too Josh would not go
in the closet and be like oh I hate that
shirt of Becca's and then get rid of her
shirt
[Laughter]
that's what she was wearing but I could
tell in that moment she didn't like it
it didn't feel good to her and so I was
like Max I be I like it just fine but
what matters is how you feel about that
sweater and if you feel like oh I just
don't feel comfortable in this it
doesn't feel like me it's okay you can
let it go and with your career and with
your relationships because how many of
us wear job titles that don't fit where
dating relationships that don't fit wear
career aspirations and all other sorts
of things that don't fit just because
somebody says Hey being a banker looks
good on you driving that car looks good
on you but the whole time you feel out
of place you feel awkward you feel
stressed you feel tight like you're not
yourself but somebody says it looks good
on you so you make yourself wear it it's
not a good look you got a good life I
hate that thing so I'm going to let it
go did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free